[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportage sur public c'est la 90 minutes
pour donner du sens à l'actualité grâce
à nos experts et voici le sommaire de ce
12 juin que restera-t-il de Silvio
Berlusconi que retiendra l'Histoire les
succès politiques les victoires
sportives l'empire médiatique ou bien
les scandales sexuels et financiers
l'ancien Premier ministre italien est
mort ce matin à l'âge de 86 ans et même
s'ils sont influence avait décliné c'est
une page importante qui se tourne pour
son pays on explore les multiples
facettes du cavalierré dans une minute
et puis pour notre second débat vous le
savez volontairement décalé de
l'actualité du jour c'est la grande
misère de la psychiatrie française que
l'on va analyser
d'occupation des lits ce qui veut dire
qu'on a des patients qui qui dorment sur
des batailles qui sont posés par terre
qui ont pas accès à des placards des
chambres de Dolly qui sont transformées
en chambre de trois lits on a même plus
de place pour qu'ils puissent manger
confortablement donc souvent c'est des
champs qui qui mangent à 600 déchets
avec des plateaux posés sur leurs genoux
trois semaines après la mort d'une
infirmière poignardée par un homme
souffrant de grave trouble psychiatrique
et pourtant laissé en liberté on fera le
constat de ce secteur en souffrance et
on est ce qui sera des solutions pour
sortir de la crise avec nous inviter
experts mais d'abord donc c'est la mort
d'un milliardaire doublé d'un animal
politique que nous raconte tout de suite
Cécile
c'est une figure emblématique de la vie
politique italienne
Silvio Berlusconi n'est plus il avait 86
ans les hommages se multiplient à
commencer par celui de la chef du
gouvernement italien Georgia Meloni
était avant tout un battant
de défendre ses convictions et ses
précisément son courage et sa
détermination qui ont fait de lui l'un
des hommes les plus influents de
l'histoire de l'Italie
homme influent il commence sa carrière
dans l'immobilier dans les années 60 où
il se fait un nom ou plutôt un surnom il
cavalierait hérité d'une distinction de
chevaliers du travail dans les années 80
l'homme d'affaires veut étendre son
empire il investit dans la presse et
fonde médiaset la fusion de plusieurs
chaînes de télé privées italiennes cet
engagement dans les médias lui vaut une
grande partie de sa fortune mais est
aussi un tremplin pour sa carrière
politique je crois qu'il a su utiliser
les moyens modernes jamais contemporain
de communication donc c'était aussi un
homme de média et la suite tiré parti
pour défendre ses idées et pour
progresser en Italie comme en Europe il
a su profiter si je puis dire de tous
ces éléments de modernité 4 ans après la
création de son parti Forza Italia il
accède en 1994 au poste de président du
conseil il le sera trois fois neuf ans
au total un record des mandats émaillés
par une série de scandales privées
sexuelle et financier qui n'empêcheront
pas Silvio Berlusconi de rester en
Italie une figure un des boulonnable de
la vie politique il a toujours tenu à
conserver à pied parce que c'est aussi
une façon outre quand il était au
pouvoir de faire passer des législations
qui étaient à son avantage économique et
industrielle de se protéger contre je
dirais des recours en justice parce que
des irrégularités nombreuses les procès
ont été nombreux et quelque part grâce à
une certaine immunité parlementaire et
il a cru il a pu se préserver
la victoire est symbolique Silvio
Berlusconi se savait déjà malade
on va explorer certaines de ces facettes
de Silvio berlusconil il y en a
tellement avec Ludmila connaît bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes historienne
spécialiste de l'Italie médiévale et
contemporaine et chercheuse associée à
l'Université Paris 1 Patrick Martin
Genier bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
professeur à Sciences Po spécialiste des
questions européennes et auteur de ce
livre l'Europe a-t-elle un avenir un
livre publié aux éditions au Studyrama
Patricia Lemonnier bonsoir Patricia
bienvenue à vous gore Panther
spécialiste des relations
internationales on est également en
duplex avec Fabien Archambeau historien
maître de conférence à l'Université
parisien Panthéon Sorbonne bonsoir à
vous vous êtes spécialiste du sport au
20e siècle et Mathieu croissanto
guitariste politique bonsoir Mathieu
bienvenue à vous aussi je vais commencer
par un premier tour de table pas facile
une Mila connaît parce que je disais
tellement de facettes si vous deviez
retenir une image je sais pas une date
une déclaration de berlusconibles vous
choisissez quoi alors
je pourrais a commencé en négatif
vraiment à sa déclaration qu'elle a fait
à une jeune femme en disant vous ne
trouvez pas du travail mais vous avez
qu'à trouver voilà vous mettre avec mon
mon fils par exemple pourquoi pas donc
c'est un peu ça conception c'est celle
des femmes qui voilà qui a travers des
hommes voilà c'est une idée ce la
question la plus importante qui qu'il
faut dans mon sens ré-obtenir c'est son
premier gouvernement son premier
gouvernement en 94 lorsqu'il a permis
aux parties post fasciste de John
francofing qui ensuite est devenu fatale
et Little d'aller au gouvernement en
même temps qu'en partie qui était la
Ligue du Nord qui était un parti
totalement régionaliste très xénophobe
déjà et il a permis cette coalition là
et de ces deux parties qui étaient en
fréquentables pour la plupart des gens
ils les ont pu accéder au gouvernement
avec son parti fatale
Patrick Martin Geny il y a une date je
sais que dont vous voulez nous parler de
2 juillet 2003 que se passe-t-il ce
jour-là on est au Parlement européen on
est au Parlement européen l'Italie
exerce la présidence du Conseil de
l'Union européenne depuis le 1er juillet
jusqu'au mois de décembre si
intervient devant le Parlement européen
et un député allemand socialiste
social-démocrate l'interpelle je crois
que c'était Martin Schulz qui allait
lui-même de venir président plus tard et
donc il interpelle d'une façon très
critique et serviette se lève prend la
parole et dit vous savez il y a un
producteur en ce moment qui va tourner
un film sur les camps de concentration
et vous pourriez être le capot le chef
du camp de concentration provoquant un
scandale diplomatique dès le lendemain
de la présidence du Conseil de l'Union
européenne un scandale en Allemagne la
stupéfaction au sein des députés
socialistes allemands vous pouvez
imaginer ce que ça a été et donc cette
présidence a très mal commencé tout ça
pour vous dire que lorsqu'on est un
leader national on exerce des
responsabilités européennes et
internationales et bien évidemment
chasser naturel il revient au galop très
souvent il peut y avoir des chocs
diplomatiques au niveau européen et on
reviendra évidemment il vous sur ces le
son poids européen d'une certaine façon
on en parlera un petit peu plus tard
Patricia lemonnière vous nous dites que
d'une certaine façon il a été pionnier
en quoi a-t-il été pionnier Sylvie vieux
j'ai envie de dire qu'il était pleurer
dans l'art de la de la disruption si le
mot on peut peut exister c'est-à-dire
que immédiatement vous citez cet exemple
vous en citer vous incitez un autre il
est le pionnier parce que il va ouvrir
cette aire ou des hommes d'affaires
investissent massivement dans le sport
ou des manières du bâtiment investissent
dans les médias quitte à les contrôler à
50% comme en Italie et où il va ouvrir
le champ politique à atout c'est ce
courant
décomplexé il a été copié après en
quelque sorte il a eu des des
successeurs et le plus notoire de tous
les successeurs on pourrait dire que
cette Trump parce que c'est aussi un
homme de média c'est aussi un
businessman et c'est aussi un homme qui
a voulu tourner la politique à son
avantage et pas forcément à l'avantage
de son pays mais en tout cas à son
profit et on pourrait rajouter
quelques-uns des scandales aussi qui qui
ont marqué la carrière de Berlusconi et
celle et celle de Trump effectivement
une impunité en terme politique une
impunité évidemment en termes judiciaire
puisque il a été beaucoup poursuivi et
rarement condamné une fois je crois de
mémoire et c'est le c'est exactement ce
qui vient d'être dit c'est à dire c'est
l'apparition de leaders qui s'en foutent
de la respectabilité de des contingences
de tout ce qu'on disait avant des mots
mais c'est impossible dans lui c'est pas
grave et c'est vrai qu'il a d'une
certaine façon éclater un plafond de
verre pour toute une palanquée de leader
popul ensuite qui joue ça à l'opinion
directe contre les médias contre les
élites contre avec scandales auquel
d'autres auparavant n'ont jamais relevé
voilà c'est effectivement intéressant
Fabien Chambon pour les fans de sport
français notamment Berlusconi c'est la
la rivalité avec Bernard Tapie la Coupe
d'Europe remportée par l'Olympique de
Marseille en 93 par le contre le Milan
AC qui était le club de Berlusconi des
Coupes d'Europe il en a remporté
beaucoup des championnats italiens aussi
à quel point le foot lui a servi de
marche-pied vers sa carrière politique
expliquez-nous
alors ça c'est alors il y a rien
d'étonnant sur le fait que un homme
politique s'occupe de football en Italie
c'est une tradition qui s'est installée
dès les années 50 60 il y a une
trentaine de parlementaires italiens qui
sont présidents de club de football ce
qui est plus intéressant avec
berlusconis c'est quand il rentre en
politique donc en 1994
il file totalement la métaphore du
football
avec son action politique donc déjà il
choisit la disais à une Campo donc
l'entrée sur le terrain sont partis
s'appelle Forza italiens parce que il
avait réussi à à partir de son club qui
était un des clubs de Milan le Milan AC
à devenir en gros une sorte de patron du
football italien puisque l'entraîneur de
l'équipe nationale c'est l'ancien
entraîneur du bilan assez par exemple et
alors surtout après comment est-ce qu'on
rentre en politique alors qu'on n'a pas
de parti politique on en crée un à
partir de rien
choisissez maintenant il y a eu des
travaux de sociologue qui sont
intéressés à ça que il s'est appuyé sur
le réseau des supporters du bilan AC
puisque c'est aussi pour ça qu'il a
choisi le Milan AC en 1986 c'est une des
grandes équipes nationales avec l'Inter
de Milan et la Juventus de Turin qui ont
des supporters dans toute l'Italie et
donc il y a les Mylène club qui en 1994
sont mobilisés pour constituer le
premier réseau de supporters non plus
footballistique mais politique de force
à italiens le nouveau parti de
Berlusconi donc de ce point de vue là en
fait il a systématisé et pousser à bout
une logique qui était sous-jacente en
Italie depuis une trentaine d'années qui
est que le football permet de parler de
politique et il a poussé ce système là à
son paroxysme c'était un personnage
évidemment hors norme alors il avait
commencé en vendant des aspirateurs en
porte-à-porte et puis surtout en
chantant chantait dans des boîtes de
nuit chanter sur des sur des paquebots
il faut donner aussi en français
souvenir de ces années d'étudiants à la
Sorbonne regardez cette vidéo qui date
de 2006 la qualité est pas top mais on
entend Pigalle ils chantent en français
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est le grand marché de l'amour
près de couenne ou d'un boulot voilà
pour quelques quelques
notes à fredonnées par sylview
Berlusconi c'est drôle parce que ce
talent de chanteur il l'avait mis à
profit au milieu des années 80 quand il
recevait chez lui en Italie à Milan les
stars de la télé française ils créent
ils créent la 5 à l'époque et il se
mettait au piano il avait un gigantesque
piano blanc et il se mettait au piano et
il les accueillaient en chanson et avec
aussi un carnet de chèques évidemment
bien rempli on va en parler avec Steve
Jourdain tout de suite de cet aspect de
la carrière de Silvio Berlusconi bonsoir
Steve très jolie chemise bienvenue à
vous extrait pour votre je sais bien
c'est pour ça que je vous félicite
c'était donc un homme de média Sylvie
oui après avoir fait fortune dans
l'immobilier et se lancent dans
l'audiovisuel je vais y arriver on est
dans les années 70 le secteur est en
pleine mutation c'est le tout début de
la libéralisation la rail le très
puissant service public se voit
progressivement concurrencé par les
initiatives privées septembre 78
Berlusconi lance télé Milano une chaîne
locale diffusée sur le câble est déjà
malgré la concurrence de la rail il y a
l'ambition d'entrer dans la cour des
grands écoutez
il n'est pas facile de créer une chaîne
de télévision car il n'existe aucun
espace pour la télévision privée il n'y
a pas de technicien disponible car ils
sont tous à la rail nous devons donc
former des jeunes qui deviendront petit
à petit des professionnels
deux autres chaînes privées dont les
comptes sont dans le rouge il taille ya
uno arrêté quattro petit à petit son
Groo va concurrencer la rail et devenir
un véritable empire audiovisuel au fil
du temps il contrôlera pas moins de 90%
de l'audience et des recettes
publicitaires du secteur privé Thomas et
j'en parlais à l'instant son appétit
s'est étendu à la France oui au début de
l'année 86 avec la bénédiction de
François Mitterrand alors président
Berlusconi participe au lancement de la
5 c'est la toute première chaîne privée
gratuite en France pour la première fois
les films sont coupés par de la
publicité ce qui fera râler d'ailleurs
un certain nombre de réalisateurs la
recette Berlusconi est très simple du
strass des paillettes de belles gueules
à l'antenne et surtout surtout de la
légèreté regardez
[Musique]
sur la 5 les jeux et les libertés
Gallia vous attendent aux escales du
rire et des chansons pour gagner les
cadeaux les plus inattendus les
concurrences getano et la main passe à
toute vitesse bon le son date un peu
aussi du milieu des années 80 ça s'est
pas très bien terminé c'est non faible
audience trop petite couverture du
territoire grave difficulté financières
la 5 mais la clé sous la porte 6 ans
plus tard en 92 ça va laisser le temps à
balusconi de préparer son entrée en
politique deux ans plus tard sont partis
Forza Italia se présente législatives et
Berlusconi devient chef du gouvernement
italien merci merci beaucoup Steve pour
toutes ces informations le millet
comment il crée cette empire médiatique
sur sur quel levier il joue d'abord il
va bénéficier très vite d'un décret par
bettino-craxie leader du Parti
socialiste italien qui va lui permettre
de contourner les lois en titre d'abord
il avait fait une maîtrise en droit
là-dessus pour savoir comment contourner
cela et ensuite lorsqu'il commence à
avoir ses télévisions il ne pouvait pas
avoir une chaîne nationale c'était pas
permis c'était que la raille qui avait
le droit et donc il se fait faire un
décret spécifique pour lui permettre de
aller de l'avant et de faire son empire
médiatique déjà c'est une première chose
et ensuite il va utiliser vraiment
l'empire médiatique bien sûr qu'il est
en train de créer
sa puissance dans l'immobilier
n'oublions pas qui a été aussi membre de
la loge P2 le football et voilà toute
une série de de réseaux qui ont été mis
en place déjà par sa famille et par son
père n'oublions pas n'est pas un enfant
de paysan oui parce que il raconte à des
histoires là-dessus il enjolivait en
quelque sorte l'histoire du petit garçon
d'une famille pauvre qui s'est fait tout
seul
c'est une légende absolue ça Patricia
lemonnière je le racontais mais je crois
que vous étiez à TF1 en 86 il avait
sorti le carnet de chèque pour les les
grands noms de la télévision tout ce
n'était pas allé d'ailleurs mais il
avait effectivement sorti le carnet de
chèques des géants de TF1 de France 2
partaient et même des jeunes reporters
qui avaient quelques années de maison
ont été tentés par l'aventure évidemment
mais en même temps il y avait cette
crainte parce que Berlusconi c'était la
télévision spaghetti Coca-Cola
d'ailleurs il avait fait dans une
annonce il avait dit mais ça sera en
France bon bah ça sera peut-être pas
Coca-Cola mais ça sera Beaujolais et
alors voyez journaliste bon la
télévision Beaujolais c'était peut-être
pas l'idéal mais bon il avait le don
d'attirer
par l'argent et puis par la séduction
Patrick partage politiquement il faut
commencer à quand même à vous de laver
évoqué tout à l'heure mais il a toujours
été à droite et allié au parti de droite
si Dieu Berry oui enfin il est ce qu'on
appelle en Italie le chunthrodestre
c'est-à-dire la centre droit il n'a
jamais été alors on dit en Italie il a
été anti
anti-communiste anti fasciste donc c'est
quelqu'un qui était véritablement dans
la lignée du centre droit italien donc
c'était un homme d'État effectivement
parce que il a fait pas mal tout de même
de réalisation on pourra en parler un
peu plus et il s'est incarné il a lancé
son parti Forza Italia qui était un
parti de centre droit qui peu à peu
s'est fait grignoter malheureusement au
cours des années 2000 2010 2020 pas
l'extrême droite la meilleure preuve
c'est Madame mélonie et Matteo Salvini
qui l'ont grignotait à tel point qu'il
n'a pas pu revenir au pouvoir comme il
le souhaitait mais c'est véritablement
donc l'incarnation du centre droit c'est
quelqu'un qui aimait fondamentalement
son pays je me rappelle aussi une autre
date le 26 janvier
1994 il lance son la force à italienne
et ils disent l'Italie c'est le pays que
j'aime donc c'est vrai qu'on a dit que
il était l'incarnation d'une sorte de
populisme mais c'est quelqu'un qui n'a
jamais varié il n'a jamais été à
l'extrême droite mais sa difficulté a
été de contenir l'extrême droite et il
s'est toujours allié en fin de compte à
l'extrême droite il y a eu Matéo Salvini
il y a eu la dent qui était la Ligue il
y a eu Fratelli d'Italia avec Madame
mélony et on a vu que malheureusement
son score son emprise électorale avait
diminué au cours de ces années mais
c'est un homme d'État qui restera
effectivement dans l'histoire peut-être
pas de la démocratie chrétienne mais du
centre droit plutôt libéral trop
entreprise qui a gouverné l'Italie
pendant un certain nombre d'années
que fait François Mitterrand est très
surprenant parce que la gauche au
pouvoir se souvenir de ce que c'est en
1980 quand elle arrive il y a la volonté
de défendre une exception culturelle il
y a une politique culturelle très forte
qui brille en fait Mitterrand le fait
parce que il sait qu'il va perdre les
élections
qualitative et il ne veut pas laisser la
droite faire une chaîne à sa propre main
donc il le fait juste avant de perdre
ses élections il décide de le donner à
Sylvio Berlusconi qui est l'antithèse de
l'exception culturelle un peu mais bon
quand même mais il y avait quand même
une forme de fascination des deux à la
fois pour le l'homme politique qui était
Mitterrand et pour cette espèce de
corsaire des affaires que symboliser à
l'époque Sylvio est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord sur le les idées politiques
est-ce qu'il est-ce qu'il y a une
idéologie est-ce qu'il a fini par
basculer vers l'extrême droite ou pas
il a réuni l'extrême droite il a permis
à d'extrême droite de venir respectable
c'est quelqu'un qui plus que tout autre
a dynamiter la la Constitution italienne
dans tout son esprit en point du point
de vue des lois de la de la démocratie
et il a procédé il a fait procéder à des
réformes y compris institutionnelles qui
ont qui ont été clairement autoritaires
d'un point de vue
institutionnel mais aussi de la société
civile et il n'a pas
justement été mis en a jamais été
fasciste ce n'est pas ça son sa
filiation en revanche il a permis et il
a fait en sorte que certaines idées et
certains de mesures politiques soient
en place Patricia il y a un paradoxe
chez lui parce qu'il s'adresse
complètement au peuple
il y a une adhésion d'une partie d'une
grande partie de la population italienne
quand il arrive à son discours qui se
sent très proche de lui et en même temps
dans sa façon de gouverner on a
l'impression qu'il gouverne pour lui
dire qu'il fait des lois qui sont pour
lui alors que le peuple continue à le à
trouver en lui l'homme qui le représente
et il y a un côté paradoxal dans cette
façon de gouverner et d'être senti par
son électorat c'est vrai que c'était
peut-être le créateur du populisme en
Europe mais quand même j'ai tendance à
penser que la démocratie italienne a
toujours été plus forte que Silvio
berluscodi la preuve en est c'est que
bon il a démissionné à deux reprises il
a été à trois reprises présidents du
conseil il a fait voter à un certain
nombre de lois certes mais à tel point
d'ailleurs qu'il s'est incarné dans ce
qu'on est allé on appelle la Seconde
République en réalité
institutionnellement il n'y en a qu'une
celle qui a été créée en 46 mais avec
les réformes électorales les réformes
qu'il a fait voter on a parlé les
journalistes ont beaucoup parlé d'une
seconde république qui l'a incarné voilà
mais en réalité on sait très bien que
pour vous il a pas fragilisé la
démocratie
il maîtrisait les médias en tout cas il
ne l'a pas fragilisé comme le fait
madame mélonier aujourd'hui qui peut se
permettre de limoger un certain nombre
de journalistes qui a décidé de ne plus
appliquer un certain nombre de règles
européennes il est jamais allé jusque là
il n'a pas osé il est resté dans sa
tradition européenne
oui paradoxalement je voulais juste te
rappeler que cette tradition qui avait
été inauguée déjà par akila avant lui
c'est celle que au niveau des changes la
corruption généralisée qu'il a mis en
place et par ailleurs certains m'ont
demandé mais est-ce qu'il est vraiment
lié à la mafia j'ai toujours répondu il
a eu toujours oui siège sur 8 dans les
élections législatives en Sicile je n'ai
rien à ajouter vous voyez ce que je veux
dire voilà bon vouliez intervenir
peut-être pour faire le lien entre son
empire médiatique et sportif et sa
carrière politique comment il a utilisé
l'un pour pour l'autre
oui non c'était aussi plus sur le début
de sa carrière politique
en fait moi j'ai l'impression que
Berlusconi est enfin ça a été dit ça pas
un idéologue il aurait très bien pu être
gauche face à pourquoi est-ce qu'il
intervient pourquoi est-ce qu'il rentre
en politique en 1994 parce qu'il est lié
et ça il doit sa carrière son empire
médiatique au Parti socialiste italien
de bettylocraxie et après l'opération
manipulite entre 91 et 92 avec la
disparition de la démocratie chrétienne
en gros il a peur de finir en prison
comme Betty no craxier qui doit s'exiler
en Tunisie dans ces années là donc en
fait le son entrée en politique il
choisit le centre droit parce que en
gros c'est la place à prendre du fait de
l'implosion de la démocratie chrétienne
mais son camp politique sont vrais camps
politiques c'est le parti socialiste
italien la partie socialiste libéral
pour les réformes qui ressemblent
beaucoup à ce qu'elle participe de la
deuxième partie des années 80 et ce qui
explique après son mode de
fonctionnement en fait
quand on a pas d'idéologie alors il
ressort
l'anticommunisme mais qui n'a plus lieu
d'être puisqu'il y a plus de parti
communiste en Italie et surtout un
énorme culte de la personnalité comme
vous l'avez dit c'est-à-dire si vous
regardez ces clips de campagne pour la
campagne de 2001 ou celle de 2008 c'est
totalement délirant c'est-à-dire que
c'est sa présence une Italie qui est
éperdu d'amour face à son chef et
effectivement merci Fabien et
effectivement des médias en grande
partie à sa botte qui faisait ça à sa
campagne électorale Patrick oui il
venait à l'esprit une comparaison avec
un responsable politique français qui
est Bernard Tapie est-ce que Bernard
Tapie il a touché à tout il a fait de la
politique il a fait du sport à Marseille
il a remonté de l'intrigue de Marseille
c'est quelqu'un qui était dans les
affaires et qui a eu des affaires
également judiciaires assez
considérables très importantes donc ce
sont des gens qui ont touché à tous les
secteurs notamment politiques d'un tapis
était ministre et voilà mais par rapport
à d'autres comparaisons vous on a dit
c'était un peu le Trump etc mais je
pense que Berlusconi avait quand même
une vraie culture politique il avait la
culture de son pays l'amour de son pays
ancré en lui-même et je crois que même
s'il avait un gros ego même s'il a
effectivement mis le moto il a investi
dans les médias et bien c'est quelqu'un
qui avait l'amour de son pays et qui
avait une culture politique assez
minimum qu'on demande
pas forcément non plus vous disiez il
n'a jamais gouverné que pour lui et donc
oui enfin bon je suis un peu plus
réservé quand même parce que il a été
présent à des moments clés de l'histoire
européenne et si vous voulez on pourra
en reparler parce que dans les saluer a
été même s'il n'avait pas une culture
profonde européenne et s'il était
pragmatique c'est quelqu'un qui a
toujours été présent pourra faire
avancer la construction européenne et
sur ce point on a pu compter sur lui je
sais pas si je vois vous êtes pas
forcément d'accord mais en préparant
l'émission On a dans un article de
France 24 il y a il il rappelait
qu’après une décennie de pouvoir le
magazine britannique maïs Nico the
économiste titrait à propos de
Berlusconi l'homme qui a bousillé tout
un pays alors c'était sans doute exagéré
mais il a connu est-ce qu'il voilà si on
faisait si on fait le bilan sa première
décennie pour rebondir sur ce titre là
les coups de boutoirs contre la
Constitution italienne née dans la
résistance c'est Berlusconi et les a
donné un premier et ce que fait
aujourd'hui le gouvernement actuel c'est
lui qui l'a initié il a commencé par
dynamiter les premières les principaux
acquis de cette constitution et il a
ouvertement dit il fallait la dépasser
il fallait la changer parce que ça
l'empêchait lui et ses amis de faire des
affaires librement selon voilà un état
de droit et avec
une démocratie et une représentabilité
sociale c'est de ça qu'il s'agit il a
fait ça toute sa vie et dès qu'il a pu
travailler 93 94 il a fait ça il a mis
en place des changements institutionnels
il a sabordé les syndicats la
représentation de la société et tout ce
qu'il a été fait c'est c'est ce qui a
produit la situation actuelle alors
effectivement il faut rappeler que le
Parti socialiste aimant de la de la
coalition qui a mené Georgia Meloni au
pouvoir et forcément elle lui a rendu
hommage la chef du gouvernement italien
aujourd'hui
qu'elle ne devait jamais se laisser
imposer de limites elle a appris que
nous devons jamais renoncer avec lui
nous avons mené gagner et perdu de
nombreuses batailles et c'est aussi pour
lui que nous atteindrons les objectifs
que nous nous étions fixés ensemble
avec l'utilité l'Italie a appris qu'elle
ne devait jamais se laisser imposer de
limite je trouve ça intéressant parce
que cette phrase on peut la lire de deux
façons effectivement le l'ambition mais
aussi le fait que il se soit franchi des
limites et peut-être même ce que vous me
disiez de certaines limites
démocratiques est-ce que Patricia
lemonnière l'influence politique faut
l'évaluer aujourd'hui c'est à dire elle
avait elle avait décliné quand même ces
dernières années qu'est-ce que vous en
diriez
dans le climat italien sur cette plus de
30 dernières années
sont depuis qu'il avait été condamnés
et en 94 si je ne fais si je ne fais pas
d'erreur et qui ne pouvait plus être élu
il avait perdu ses ou ses 92 ou 93 en
2013 2013 je crois que la bonne date
c'est 2013 effectivement 2013 2019 je
crois et qu'il ne pouvait plus être élu
et bien depuis c'est la fracture là il y
a quelque chose qui s'est passé qui
s'est même passé je crois dans son
électorat ça faisait suite aux affaires
effectivement
fondée sur rien et un verdict qui
m’enlève ma liberté ainsi que mes droits
politiques
Patrick Martin Genier il est condamné
pour ça mais en fait il a tellement
enfin il a tellement été poursuivi et
quasiment jamais condamné c'est aussi ça
l'histoire de Berlusconi c'est un
insubmersible c'est quelqu'un qui a une
capacité de rebondir extraordinaire
comme tous les populistes en fin de
compte je regardais avant de venir cette
émission 8 condamnations en première
instance c'est la presse italienne qui
le rappelle une seule définitive en
cassation et donc effectivement ça veut
dire qu'il a eu la capacité de rebondir
il a eu une interdiction de se
représenter aux élections mais que
fait-il après et bien il revient en
politique il revient en 2019 une est élu
députée européen d'où encore son rôle
européen et enfin il était lui sénateur
au mois d'octobre 2022 ce sera son
dernier mandat mais n'a jamais renoncé
effectivement il avait une capacité avec
beaucoup de bons avocats il faut le dire
et donc il a toujours réussi à s'en
sortir d'une certaine façon ça fait
effectivement penser à l'air Trump qui
doit faire face à son nombre de procès
donc effectivement c'est quelqu'un qui
est je sais pas on l'a vu aussi en train
de faire des travaux d'intérêt général
dans une maison de retraite il a été
condamné et il a dû faire des travaux
d'intérêt général pour aller auprès des
personnes malades et il a transformé la
condamnation et toujours dans le
spectacle c'est quelqu'un qui était dans
les médias qui se mettait toujours en
scène et bien on le voit aller aux
personnes auprès de personnes malades
âgées en train de réaliser ces travaux
d'intérêt général et il les a fait
effectivement nous ne la connais je me
demandais dans les titres de cette
émission ce que l'histoire retiendra de
de Silvio béhausconi c'est cette partie
là les scandales financiers les
scandales sexuels les orgies les soirées
boom gabunga quand comme ils le disait
lui-même
je pense que l'Italie est aussi partagé
qu'elle peut l'être lors d'un scrutin
là-dessus mais à quel point pour vous ça
abîmé l'image de ce pays c'est surtout
parce qu'on l'a su parce que la question
c'est tout on doit faire tout ça sans se
faire prendre c'est d'abord ça et la
question c'est que de toute façon c'est
ça fait partie de son personnage moi ce
qui m'intéresse d'avoir demande avant
tout c'est pas le personnage même
attachant si vous voulez même
sympathique et bien jusqu'au nimet de
quoi est-il le nom de quoi est-il le nom
dans la dans la dans la transition
politique qui est passé d'une république
qui était imparfaite mais quand même
démocratique sociale et et par le
menteur à une un laisser faire total
sans limite ou finalement c'est une
initiative individuelle ou de groupe qui
il y avait pardon de l'interromps il y
avait déjà de la corruption avant il y
avait déjà des affaires avant en
rappelait à Fabien argent nous rappelait
manipulite l'opération enfin bon c'est
pas qu'est-ce que Silvio Berlusconi
change sur cet aspect de la démocratie
italienne pour vous
[Musique]
la capacité italienne au moment de la
fameuse opération main propre il a dit
j'incarne autre chose que les parties il
était totalement disruptif mot à la mode
aujourd'hui en dire je vais passer au
dessus de tous les partis
les réactions en France Mathieu comment
la classe politique française voilà a
réagi à la mort de Sylvio de façon très
contrastée presque à l'image du
personnage côté officiel en cette fin
d'après-midi ou nous nous enregistrons
cette émission le silence règne rien de
la part de l'Élysée rien de la part du
ministère des Affaires étrangères rien
de la part de l'ambassade de France à
Rome qui de toute façon ne ferait que
reproduire ce qu'on fait les premiers ça
traduit au mieux une gêne alors il faut
dire que la personnalité sulfureuse
facile parce que on est quand même à
l'heure de la lutte contre les violences
sexistes à l'heure de la lutte contre le
populisme ou encore de la lutte contre
la fraude fiscale et la corruption et
bien l'ancien président du Conseil
italien de du Conseil italien pardon
fait figure de contre modèle pour ne pas
dire de repoussoir alors Berlusconi ne
patin ne partage rien avec Emmanuel
Macron ni sa politique ni son humour en
souviens qui s'était moqué de sa femme
en 2017 ni ses alliances donc pas
question au sommet de l'État ou pour
l'Elysée de le pleurer comme l'ont fait
aujourd'hui par exemple Vladimir Poutine
ou Victor urban parce que Emmanuel
Macron nous partage pas non plus les
alliances de verlusion sur le reste de
l'équipe alors la droite comme l'extrême
droite semble avoir choisi de séparer
l'homme de l'artiste que si je peux me
permettre comme on dit à un point qui
confine parfois au surréalisme erikioti
par exemple le patron DLR salut la
mémoire d'un véritable monument de la
politique un homme d'État qui l'a servi
de toutes ses forces ainsi qu'un fervent
défenseur de l'amitié entre nos deux
nations voilà rien de plus non je t'ai
plus même le RN préfère marquer une
forme de distance parce que Marine Le
Pen se contente de dépeindre un
personnage atypique à la vie hors norme
et au parcours fulgurant on voit que ce
sont quand même pas les mêmes mots et
l'adresse ses condoléances au peuple
italien et puis sans surprise c'est du
côté de reconquête Marion maréchal qui
voyait la disparition on en parlait tout
à l'heure
précurseur de la fameuse union des
droites parce que c'est ça qui restera
de Berlusconi c'est quand même le
premier pays fondateur de l'Union
européenne qui fait péter la digue entre
la droite et l'extrême droite et ça
l'Union des droits de c'est évidemment
ce qu'elle appelle de ses vœux Marion
maréchal alors il faut dire qu'elle est
aussi l'épouse d'un ancien proche de
Matteo Selvini qui avec lequel le sigle
berrichoni on l'a rappelé avec plusieurs
plusieurs fois c'était allié plusieurs
fois pour conquérir le pouvoir donc ça
c'est à droite de l'électricité et à
gauche alors à gauche même silence même
gêne on en croirait presque de la part
des anciens comme des nouveaux
hiérarques du Parti socialiste que ils
sont pas pressés de voir rappeler ce
qu'on rappelait tout à l'heure c'est à
dire que les portes de l'audiovisuel
française français pardon furent ouverte
au cavaliers par François Mitterrand
j'ai trouvé quand même une exception
Jack Lang quand même le roi des hommages
mortuaires donc Jack Lang qui lui
explique que son exception culturelle à
la française c'est quand même très
différent de ce qui s'est passé en
Italie et ça permet de sauver le cinéma
français par rapport au cinéma italien
ça c'est pour le bilan de Jacques Tang
et il dit ça tombe bien que la seule
pointe désaccord avec François
Mitterrand fut justement en 1986
l'attribution de la 5 à l'italien et
puis voilà parce qu'on se rappelle que
même l'aventure télévisée le fut de
courte durée ben François Mitterrand fut
le président français préféré d'une
certaine façon de Silvio berluscoli
parce que avec ses successeurs ça c'est
moins bien passé avec Jacques Chirac
souviens qu'il avait fait visiter sa
maison pour lui montrer à la fois ses
magazines de charme et puis le bidet ou
soi-disant c'était laver beaucoup
beaucoup de fesses selon lesconi Jacques
Chirac on était resté bouche B c'est
dire et puis Nicolas c'est avec Nicolas
Sarkozy euh il y avait pas non plus de
très très bonne relation et très
récemment d'ailleurs en janvier dernier
si vous regardez ce que c'est avait fait
une interview pour dire à quel point il
trouvait que Sarkozy avait été arrogant
quand il était au pouvoir alors il y a
une chose qu'on a qu'on a merci Mathieu
qu'on a qu'on a pas encore rappelé même
si on a un peu rapidement évoqué c'est
la la longévité de siriau Berlusconi au
pouvoir 17 ans la plus grande longévité
d'un président du Conseil d'après
ministre depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale en Italie Patrick Martin Genier
est-ce que ça lui a permis cette
longévité parce que c'est un atout en
Europe est-ce que ça lui a permis de
peser en Europe ah oui je crois d'accord
donc globalement sur la durée trois
temps séparés de président du conseil
vous savez qu'en Italie c'est bien le
président du conseil qui gouverne qui a
réalisé du pouvoir et non pas le
président de la République et lorsque
vous regardez effectivement le mandat de
Silvio le second mandat entre le mois de
juin 2001 et 2006 c'est à cette période
qu'on prépare le traité de Lisbonne on
lance une Convention sur l'avenir de
l'Europe la convention la déclaration de
laïken au Conseil européen en 2002 en
2003 qui va permettre d'aboutir après
donc à cette à ce traité Lisbonne et
l'Italie aura été constamment aux côtés
de la France et de l'Union européenne
aussi en 2004 alors qu'il était
président du conseil c'est 10 pays qui
rentrent dans l'Union européenne
européenne donc il a fallu effectivement
également l'appui de l'Italie donc ce
qu'on peut dire effectivement c'est que
cette longévité a permis à l'Italie de
continuer même si ce n'était pas la
démocratie chrétienne ou des socialistes
de continuer cette oeuvre d'intégration
européenne mais Mathieu parler de
Nicolas sarkony comment il a été
considéré on va dire par Nicolas Sarkozy
ou une Américaine par exemple ben vous
avez tout à fait raison en réalité il a
jamais été très très au sérieux et je
rappelle une conférence de presse au
mois d'octobre
2010 2001 donc au mois d'octobre 2001 se
réunit un Conseil européen ou
effectivement il allait démissionner peu
de temps après excusez-moi oui c'est en
octobre 2011 pardon pas 2001 ou
effectivement il y a une conférence de
presse
quelques temps avant qu'il allait partir
du pouvoir où on demande donc à Angela
Merkel les journalistes demandent Angela
Merkel a Nicolas Sarkozy s'ils sont
s'ils font confiance pour faire des
réformes en matière économique et là il
y a eu un gros trou un gros silence et
les deux chefs d'états gouvernement se
sont regardés en réalité ils ont
considéré que ils devraient faire ce
qu'il devait faire ben jusqu'au ni mais
il n'y avait aucun aucun crédit a dû
accorder sur la réforme de l'Italie et
donc il n'était pas très pris au sérieux
en réalité parce qu'il plaisantait
toujours une maîtrisait pas toujours ses
dossiers il était là en tant qu'artiste
en tant que homme de cinéma homme de
média il ne contrôlait pas toujours mais
en voilà en réalité il y avait la forme
et le fond on va terminer sur les
relations entre berlusion Berlusconi et
Vladimir Poutine mais est-ce qu'il y a
deux perceptions là on parle de de
l'image européenne d'un d'un site vieux
Berlusconi est-ce qu'il y a deux
perceptions une perception italienne de
son bilan et une perception européenne
je rappelais le titre de the économistes
qui a il y a quelques minutes un point
de vue européen il est absolument
infréquentable sur un certain nombre de
choses on a parlé de ce qu'il a dit à
Monsieur Schulz qui absorbe absolument
incroyable absolument incroyable ces
phrases etc etc donc italiens oui il y a
quelque part j'ai compris pour sa
longévité Berlusconi c'est l'héritier
d'andéréotype pour ceux qui connaissent
c'est celui qui lui ressemble de plus
même s'ils sont totalement différents
comme voilà là incarné la Première
République lui incarne la seconde la
transition donc pour la seconde c'est
longévité cette façon non pas simplement
personnelle mais aussi par les appuis
et la longévité elle vient de beaucoup
de des appuis qui sont les leurs et
cette capacité justement à être
inoxydable comme disait aussi on disait
de andriotti vous voyez c'est un peu un
peu ça donc c'est un personnage qui a
tellement traversé la vie des Italiens
qu'il devient sympathique il est
sympathique objectivement alors sur la
question de de Poutine il y a des
anecdotes comme ça sur le lit de Poutine
que qui ont été qui ont été offerts à
Berlusconi par justement Vladimir
Poutine pendant une de leurs rencontres
il y a toute une voilà une mise en scène
comme ça
viriliste un peu et qui fait qui fait
rire les gens voyez on va y revenir sur
ce lien entre Poutine et Berlusconi on
écoute d'abord la réaction du président
russe c'est très court
c'est une grande perte non seulement
pour l'Italie mais aussi pour le monde
politique c'est très court mais Patricia
lemonnière évidemment c'est c'est
important de voir que Vlady routine
réagit officiellement réagit rapidement
le disait Mathieu tout à l'heure que
comment vous qualifiez la relation
politique entre entre ces deux ces deux
personnalités je pense qu'il y a une
vraie complicité qui s'est créée dès le
début une espèce de d'amitié dans dans
de deux hommes qui sont décidés à
gouverner selon leur tempo et donc on le
voit très bien d'ailleurs en plus
Berlusconi un jour se vantait d'être un
des cinq amis un des cinq amis a mis un
dessin Camille de Vladimir Poutine et
d'être le premier des cinq
alors voyez il a peu d'amis Vladimir
Poutine mais il se vantait d'être le
premier dessin autre phrase tout de
suite en Ukraine il lui a apporté pour
la pour lors de l'invasion il a dit ma
foi l'Ukraine c'était la faute de
l'invasion en Ukraine non mais c'était
l'Ukraine qui avait attaqué Poutine et
qui avait attaqué les forces russes donc
vous voyez il avait cette façon de se
ranger toujours près de Poutine mais
parce qu'il y avait entre une complicité
il se recevait dans leur Dacia
respective dans leur villégiature de
vacances et ils avaient ce côté à la
fois d'hommes sportif qui se voulait
sportif qui se voulait
au delà de tous les les les conventions
les redevient des conventions politiques
traditionnelles et on se sentait se
retrouver et puis je retiens ce que vous
dites l'amitié viriliste effectivement
je pense qu'il y a ça aussi dans le dans
l'iconographie des deux des deux
personnages publics et médiatiques qui
avaient ça ce visage qu'il faut le
souligner quand même parce qu'on en a
pas parlé qui ne bougera pas c'est un
des rares
il était tellement maquillé que quand
Jacques Chirac avait pour Premier
ministre Jean-Pierre Raffin d'habitude
c'est le chef de l'État qui devait le
saluer en premier mais il envoyait
Jean-Pierre Raffin l'embrassait en
premier pour que ce soit lui qui donc
très bonne anecdote qui récupère le
maquillage très bon anecdote tiens on va
terminer avec une autre anecdote et je
vous redonne la parole une dernière fois
Fabien Archambault pour reparler un peu
sport parce que il avait revendu le
bilan assez donc le club mythique dont
vous nous parliez et puis racheter un
petit club de troisième division je
crois que c'est Monza si je ne me trompe
qu'il a fait remonter mais alors le
scandale est jamais loin avec Berlusconi
qu'est-ce qui promet un jour à ses
joueurs en cas de victoire face à une
grande équipe
on a perdu Fabien Archambeau
excusez-moi je pensais que vous envoyez
un reportage sur le je voulais vous
laisser raconter une anecdote
avec des prostituées à l'intérieur voilà
voilà la façon dont Silvio Berlusconi
motivait entre autres ces joueurs ben
voilà c'est moi qui l'aurait raconté
elle était rapide et elle nous permet de
boucler ce débat merci beaucoup merci à
tous d'y avoir participé je vais
rappeler le titre de votre livre Patrick
Martin Genier l'Europe un tel un avenir
publié aux éditions Studyrama merci à
tous d'avoir participé à ce débat je
vous dis à bientôt sur public c'est